foreign
good morning good evening everyone thank
you I would like to thank the organizers
for giving me this opportunity to give
this talk so today I would like to tell
you guys a little bit more about the
story
um that I did as a graduate student when
I was in Howard Chang's lab in Stanford
So currently I'm in the genome Institute
of Singapore um I just started my own
lab there about a year ago so I'd like
to tell you about
um landscape and variation of RNA
secondary structure across the human
transcript home
as we all know in the central dogma RNA
is transcribed from DNA which is then
translated into proteins and for the
longest time um the proteins are known
as the main cellular Machinery in the
cell the ability for proteins to fold
into a secondary all tertiary structures
is critical for its function however RNA
can also fall into complex secondary and
tertiary structures
so an example of how RNA structure can
be important for cellular biology is
shown in the p27 MRNA whereby the triple
mutr of p27 actually folds into a
secondary structure whereby during
senescence uh poisons conditions
um a micro RNA binding site is actually
occluded and then hence uh the cell
remains in quizens condition and when
the cell is ready to exit out of poisons
into the cell cycle
interpoliferative State on the presence
of this iron binding protein called
palm1 binds to the primary TR of this
p27 resulting in a structural change in
the RNA conformation and then now this
microorganic binding side
is now available for binding enhancers
repression of p27 translation enhanced
cell can actually enter proliferative
state
so even though our new structures have
been known to be really important for
different aspects of cellular biology
very little RNA structure information is
actually currently available most of the
structured information that we have in
the protein database belongs to proteins
so there is more than 76 000 protein
Crystal structures but only if more than
900 RNA Crystal structures and most of
this are nuclear structures belong to a
few really well studied rnas such as
ribosom rnas slow rnas trnas Etc
structural information for most of the
other cellular rnas is hugely lacking
so to understand how rnas actually
function in the cell we really need to
have a good understanding of um what the
structures look like and then so to be
able to do that we developed a method
that's known as a parallel analysis of
RNA structure or parse and basically
um what we do in this method is that we
couple enzymatic RNA structure probate
to hydropriate sequencing so shown here
is the schematic of how we actually go
about doing it we isolate total RNA from
the cell and reach for mRNA and then we
fold rnas and treat it with a
double-strand nucleus known as RN is V1
it Cleaves at double threat of regions
and upon cleaving this enzyme leaves a
five Prime phosphate which enables the
cleavage side to be directly captured
and then made into a sequencing library
and upon sequencing from the five Prime
end of the re the fiber and the adapter
we're able to have an idea of where the
double-stranded regions are along the
transcription
and similarly we can use a single strand
enzyme known as S1 nucleus that cleave a
single trend of regions along an RNA and
then again upon single stranded cleavage
and adaptal ligation we can make this
into a cdna library
um that can be sequenced and such that
upon mapping we can identify where all
the single stranded regions are along
the transcriptome and it's the one we
actually have
um double and single stranded
information together we can calculate a
pass score which is basically a
likelihood of how basically a
probability of How likely it is to be
double or single stranded at a
particular base and so the higher the
more positive the Pascal is the more
likely it is to be double-stranded and
the lower the more negative the Pascal
is more likely it is to be single
stranded
and then so we utilize this method to
basically look at the human
transcriptome what do the RNA structures
in the human transcription look like are
there any global patterns
um how do different variate factors such
as single nucleotide variations affect
how our instructions fold in the human
transcriptome
so first I'd like to tell you a little
bit more about the global map of RNA
segment structures in the human
transcriptome
we
performed um RMA sorry we performed here
so we performed RNA structure probing in
a family of three individuals the father
the mother and the child and out of this
uh and
out of this when we first did
destructive probing the first thing that
we wanted to check was the out structure
probably made sense meaning what should
be single stranded does represent single
string and what should be double
stranded thus represent double Trend so
shown here is one of slow rnas and you
can see for most part the loops a single
stranded retrieved and the stems are
double stranded and
um instructional probably in human
transcription identify more than
um about 20 000 transcripts actually
um a few tens of thousands of mrnas in a
few thousand long encoding rnas
and when we average the structure signal
across all the transcripts by the
translation start or stop codons we can
actually see that in the coding region
um we actually have slightly less RNA
structure in the coding region than in
the five Prime utr all three primary TRS
and again we see a increase in
accessibility near the translation stack
codon and that is correlated with
translation efficiency and then we also
see these three nucleotide periodicity
in the coding region that we have also
seen before in yeast that also seems to
be correlated with translation
efficiency
interestingly now um so now we can
actually be able to look into specific
post-transcript code transcriptional or
post-transcriptional processes to see if
there are any RNA structures that are
associated with some of these processes
so shown here is
um across we aligned all the transcripts
across the Exon axon Junctions to see if
there is any structural profile that's
associated with splicing and as shown
here we see an increase in accessibility
towards the end of Exon one
um
immediately uh immediately before the
Exon two and um
however we currently we do not really
know what is the function of this
increasing accessibility
and then similarly now we can actually
begin to go in to look at micro RNA
binding sites and see if there are any
structural regions
um structural features that represent my
real micro RNA binding sites
um as opposed to falsely falsely
predicted macro RNA sites and so to do
this we actually utilize ago popular
data which is um basically a way to look
at RNA regions that are pulled down by
the ego protein by the equal enzyme
and what we notice is that the true
angle bound micro RNA sites are actually
more accessible than the non-able bound
predicted microorganized and you can see
in red at the true angle Bond and
they're a lot more accessible and
immediately Upstream of the actual micro
RNA binding site and we can actually go
ahead and sort
um put into this micro RNA sorts the
accessibility of this region into five
put them into five different beams and
we can actually see that the more
structured regions are actually less
likely to be able-bound and the less
structural regions are more likely to be
able
and actually when we look at
um
gene expression data so when we
overexpress a micro RNA and look at what
other targets are actually repressed by
this macro RNA we actually see that the
sites that have more that are more
accessible are actually not likely to be
I repressed to a greater extent there
are sites that are less accessible
indicating the accessibility is actually
important for micro RNA function in Vivo
so now I want to move on a little bit
into
um actually how
variation a single nucleotide mutants in
a general effect RNA structure so people
have looked at single nucleotide housing
nucleotide variations can impact our
restructure computationally so shown
here is one example of um the cftr
receptor which is really important which
is mutated in cystic fibrosis so shown
here is actually uh a tree nucleotide
that deleted in this important protein
the resist the fibrosis and for the
longest time people felt it was only it
was because of this deletion that caused
pretty misfolding and hence resulting in
the severe phenotype of this disease
however uh recently it was also
discovered that this division resulted
in a base mutation in the sequence and
then hence when you actually revert the
space back to its original sequence you
can restore the secondary structure
resulting in the restoration of the
efficiency of translation across this
region and hence um a less severe
phenotype
so computationally people have noticed
that single nucleotide variation can
cause structural changes
um and
um shows shown here again is a single
wild type how our infrastructure in the
wild type transcript takes on
predominantly one type one RNA structure
and when you actually have the
computations
um they take on different RNA structures
they shift to different ensembles
however experimentally people have not
been able to do that very well in a
global manner so shown here are two
examples of how of our of the structure
profile of father and mother and you can
see that there are three different
mutations along this region two of the
mutations in blue do not cause any
structural change and one of the
mutation in red results in a large
structural change so these are the
structural change in mutations that
we're actually looking for and we can
use parts to identify these structure
changing mutations by comparing the
structural profiles across the
individuals
so shown here is one of the examples
whereby we can see that the father
Island goes a single base mutation
um
um from a to c in the mother in the
final meteor of this gmrps 21 and by
sequencing as my sequencing we can see a
huge change in the structural profile
that is also we can reproduce by manual
for printing and you can see here on the
right which is this footprinting gel
that we can see clear structural changes
uh where there is a base signal
nucleotide
and then we can also use other ways I
different types of structure probing
methods such as shape or DNS to validate
the same structural change
and you can see that when we use this
structure prediction program known as
thick fold this single base mutation
actually causes a dramatic change in RMA
structure folding
and when we look across entire
transcription we can identify about
1900 single nucleotide variate variant
the construction change and this is
about 15 of all the single nucleotide
barriers that we identify uh expressed
between the three individuals of other
mother and the child which is much which
is a much greater number than previously
appreciated
and we can actually validate some of
these structural changes
um by doing a real specific mapping so
for example here if this father is AAA
and the mother is CC and a child's AC
then when we met uniquely across either
a the a allele or the C allu we should
be able to see reads that mapped only to
the a allele or only to the Clio and you
can see
um when it is actually a allele shown
here in the child when the snap across
the a allele the a allele profile
resembles that of the father's profile
and see a little profile for example of
the mother's profile indicating that the
sure changes the structure whatever
structure that's present in the father
is inherited by the child and whatever
functional changes in the mother is also
encouraged by the child
and then
um so now because now we have thousands
of single nucleotide
variants that change structure now we
can actually begin to look into some of
the properties and features of this
structure changing variants and what we
notice is that when these structure
changing variants are found in
double-stranded regions they tend to
become single stranded regen signal
stranded and vice versa as opposed to
becoming more and more double-stranded
or more and more single stranded
and interestingly the nucleotide content
actually influences how this how the
direction of the structure change and
how much the structural uh change occurs
so when the base changes from GC to 80
you can see that actually it tends to be
more single stranded and when the base
changes from 80 to GC it tends to gain
double strandedness and when it is a
homozygous change the magnitude of the
structural change is much much greater
than heterozygous change
and so now that we have all these
structure changing mutations we have
this question where are they located in
the transcriptome are they are conserved
do they have any function so one of the
one of the ideas is that if the
structure changes
um if the structure changes occurs in
the region that's really important to
the organism then it is not likely to be
conserved it is not likely to be
preserved because the cell needs to
survive however if the structural change
occurs
um in a re well how if the base change
occurs and there is no structural change
um then sorry if there is no structural
change but it's likely to be tolerated
however if there's a base change in the
structural change and the structural
change occurs in the functionally
important region that is likely to be
depleted because the cell really wants
to get rid of the structure changing
mutants and what we notice is that these
rival switches signatures are actually
depleted from functional regions in the
transcriptome meaning that when they are
actually in micro RNA binding sites or
in three primary TRS
um these structural changing variants
are actually
um depleted so the cells actually do not
like to have them in Dysfunctional
regions because presumably the
maintenance of our infrastructure in
these functional regions are important
and when they are disrupted affects the
cell's ability to survive
and so in summary
um I want I
um so I want to tell you that we have we
use utilized parts to identify
structures for thousands of human genes
and then we identify certain structural
features that are specific to opposed
transcriptional processes such as
slicing and microorganic Gene regulation
and we are actually able to see that
there's increasing accessibility that is
really um there's a feature of true
microorganic binding sites and this
accessibility is important for its micro
RNA for micro rnas to be able to repress
is Gene Huggins and when we look into
different factors that affect RB
structures one of which is single
nucleotide variations we identify about
15 of these single nucleotide variations
can actually cause argument structural
changes and this is really exciting to
us because people have been looking for
the single nucleotide variations in all
kinds of diseases and different human
populations and although they can
identify them how they function is still
predominantly not known and then so now
we can potentially want potential
mechanism to which it can exert its
function is actually true changing RNA
structure
and then what we notice is that many of
the structural change in mutations are
actually depleted in functional regions
and indicating that Rd structures are
actually important in many of these
functional regions such as when our
instructions are disrupted by these
mutations
um the cells are less likely to survive
and hence these mutations are likely to
be depleted
so for acknowledgments um I would like
to thank um Howard chains lab in
Stanford where a lot of this work is
done and also um currently I've now
moved to the genome Institute of
Singapore and I've sat on my own map
there
um and we are actually recruiting we're
looking for a postdocs so interested
candidates please
um feel free to email me at my email so
thank you so like I'll I would like to
take uh questions
so one of the questions is is there
enough past data now that we can take a
list of RNA mutations and rank them in
terms of their likelihood
of being diverse niches
um well yes so for yes so for the three
individuals that we have performed we do
have enough past data whether we have a
list of How likely it is to change
structure how much with um for every
single mutation we can calculate the
magnitude of structure change that is
caused by this mutation and then we can
actually rank them and then hands um
take the top ranking ones and say that
they're more likely to be rival snitches
so um so that is what we can do however
because currently we only have three
individuals so we we can only look at
the snaps or single nucleotide variants
that actually expressed in these three
individuals
um
three individuals and then so um we need
more human uh more sequencing data so
that we can actually look at more
um we can have a bigger list of uh
structure changing mutations and then so
now that you have a let's say you find a
mutation that's really interesting to
you you can actually now go in and look
into the list and say is it likely to
change structure it could be one
mechanism that affects Gene function
okay so another question is how do you
plan on validating the impact of these
mutations
so yes so this is the biggest question
because
um some of these um structure changing
mutations we really want to know what
they are doing and then so one way that
we can begin to look at it is actually
to intersect with um for example like
um one way is actually to intersect with
are they sequencing data to see if any
of these mutations structure changing
mutations are likely to result in gene
expression changes so similar to the
concept of eqtls but now we're actually
able to look at how within this Gene
whether any of these whether there's an
association with the mutation region
expression similarly we can look into
whether there's a Association of these
mutations with Rivals of profoundly
protein translation or microorganic
regulation Etc and we can go ahead and
mutate these mutations to disrupt to
like revert back these mutations disrupt
the structures to see whether it
actually affects uh Gene regulation and
another question is how do you see
different structures of the seed RNA in
different humans allies of tissues
so as long as
um the sound as long as the rnas
um are made independently as long as the
libraries are generated independently we
are able to look at
um different structures of the same RNA
the difficulty lies in when if the same
RNA take on two different confirmations
within the same cell line we will not be
able to tease apart
um the different confirmations unless
there are mutations in the between the
two unless the mutations in the RNA that
allows us to map uni weekly across
mutations if this is the same RNA with
the same sequence
in the same human cellulite um
and it takes on two different
confirmations we will not be able to
tell but if it is in different cell
lines and we can make different
libraries out of it then we will be able
to map uh back into the RNA and tell you
that they have different confirmations
so another question is can the algorithm
calculate
past score be extended Beyond single
nucleotide variation yes so we can
actually use it to also look at the
impact of deletions for example or
insertions or bigger mutations
um how they impact our structure have
you used a matter to okay so another
question is have you used your method to
determine how good in Silicon methods
for predicting RNA structure coding are
and perhaps validate which is the best
performing yeah so this is actually a
pretty good idea
um this is actually pretty good idea
um we haven't really gone ahead to do
that but I think it would be really cool
to try that okay and then what is
another one are there any agents
available to change RNA structures
so
um there are multiple agents available
to change RNA structures
um so I'm not exactly sure what you mean
so one is of course like heat so when
you heat it up you'll melt another one
uh kill trophy agents such as urea when
you add it in it tends to be more single
stranded
um so there are various agents that are
available to change RN structures or for
example
um
yeah or for example mutations or
um other
um yeah yeah so um okay so another one
if I understand right there are some
mutations to regulate mutation some
mechanisms to regular mutations
is it possible in all cells or
the regulative mechanisms at present
only in some cells to escape the
mutations
so yes so I can imagine that under a
certain selection pressures
um
under certain selection pressures
that you can have compensatory mutations
um that you can escape that you can
escape the mutation so that you can
restore the RNA structure and this is
actually a well
utilized in five also one of the ways to
predict our new structure is actually to
use phylogeny information phylogenetic
information and the way that they use it
is actually to use co-variation changes
so that is across um conservation across
multiple different species across over a
long time whereby certain structures are
maintained because there are covariation
but within the human population I think
it's a little bit too short to actually
be able to see this kind of core
variation we did notice
um that uh because originally we're
trying to see if single nucleotide
variations
um if these structural change in
mutations tend to be clustered together
or whether these structural changing
mutations tend to exist on its own
because we were wondering whether if you
have many mutations maybe it will
exaggerate the phenotype right it will
make the phenotype even stronger as
opposed to if you only have bad mutation
but surprising me what we notice is that
this single nucleotide this mutation is
a chain structure tend to be on its own
whereas mutations that do not change
structure tend to be more clustered
together and one of the possibility is
that is because there is covariation so
actually maybe one mutation causes a
structural change which then the second
mutation reverse the structural change
and then so we realize this normal
changing mutations tend to be clustered
together
so another question is have you seen
examples of RNA secondary structure
mutations that
uh lead to escape by micro RNA
regulation so
um we have not
um
so there are no examples in the
literature whereby for example the p27
trip from utr when um when it undergoes
a structural change it results in a
micro RNA side being available or not
available and also when the microorganic
site is actually available then um you
can actually uh
whether microorganism is actually
available yet it is actually uh you can
actually undergo microorganity
regulation whereas um
whereas
um when it is bound when Micron decides
if you Bound in the double stand Loop it
is not available for macaroni regulation
however in our own data we have not been
able to show that yet
um excuse me
do you think the impact of Bible
snitches could be significant enough
that they might be cancer-driving
mutations
do you know of any examples of this
so yes so we do really think that this
could be one way that we can actually
um they might actually be driving uh
cancer cancer I mean we don't really
know
um we don't have actual example of this
but for example some of these structure
changing mutations fall within the G was
loci
loci that
um non-cancer for other diseases such as
Parkinson's disease for example or
multiple sclerosis and we don't really
know
um what these nutritions are doing and
one of the possibilities is that these
mutations are actually causing these
diseases by affecting our new structure
and one way that we can actually go
about doing it is actually to do now
very systematic studies
um to um look at how these mutations
actually change cancer phenotypes so if
we actually do capacity limitations that
change the structures do you still see
the same kind of phenotype in these
diseases
so that's uh one way and so one
possibility is actually to come up with
a huge database right like if we do it
now Beyond three individuals if you can
do it in you know 100 individuals across
different continents and we can actually
curate
um all these mutations that uh cause the
structural changes so now we can
actually have this masterless robot any
disease where you have a mutation change
from base a to base B okay now go back
to this list and say oh I actually you
know this meditation causes a structural
change maybe we can now look into
whether the structural change does
anything
so
yeah
so I think that's
um
all the questions I have for now so
unless um there are more questions
okay so there is one more so then
transcripts are produced they are ex
they
exposed step by step and exist from
polymerase the individual folding system
of RNA is where full length RNA exposed
hence I'm wondering how valid they the
individual footing is okay this is a
long long study question people have
always been asking to what extent this
individual folding actually really
capturally what we see in Vivo and we
don't actually know to some extent it
does because
um to a large extent sequence do Drive
uh how an rnas fold but also a lot of
other factors such as
individual RNA RN binding proteins
effect on RNA structure so now there's
other ways enumerology no more
ionstruction problems so people cannot
systematic go in and see how similar it
is or how different
so I think my time is up so thank you
very much for um for listening to my
talk and um feel free to email me more
questions if you have any and I'll be
very happy to answer them so thank you
very much and bye